now an Israeli air strike has hit a
civilian car in the south of Lebanon
three children and their grandmother
have been killed their mother is
severely injured lebanon's foreign
minister says the country will submit a
complaint to the United Nations over the
killing of civilians let's go live to Al
jaz's Ali Hashim muin nakura in southern
Lebanon tell us more about what's been
happening along that border Ali and this
incident involving
civilians well following retaliation add
to the bombing of civilians and the
killing of three children and their
grandmother um Hezbollah launched
several CIA Rockets towards the Israeli
town of
katuna now reports from there are
showing there are impacts in this city
several impacts uh there's no uh reports
with respect to casualties also um this
day witnessed an Israeli attack on two
Lebanese uh ambulances and there were
four emergency workers who were injured
and taken to hospitals so it seems this
day uh despite the fact it started a bit
slow but we're climbing the ladder of
escalation gradually yeah uh hisbah
attacked several Israeli military
positions all over the day and the
Israelis are saying that one Israeli
civilian was killed in a guided missile
attack on a vehicle in uh the uh
settlement of Y on the Lebanese border
it it would seem that um even though the
situation had been contained it would
seem over the last few weeks along that
border that we're facing a different
situation today how high is the R Cali
of another front opening up there uh
along the border between Israel and and
Lebanon
today well F in fact it's already a
front now despite the fact the intensity
of fire here is of course qu Far Low
lower than in Gaza however the uh
enforcements the uh uh Israeli
reinforcements to the border with three
units uh present here uh the situation
on the border itself okay it's a
contained conflict but whenever we see
more civilians killed and uh things are
kind kind of going out of control and
going out of the uh Rules of Engagement
that were set by both sides and they
were trying to update them on daily
basis and we we were seeing that but now
when things are uh going towards
civilian casualties and then hezb
responding by hitting Israeli
settlements and this is by the way the
first time since the beginning of this
war that hasbullah claims directly that
they are responsible for launching
Rockets towards Israeli settlements in
the past uh uh uh situations this the
Hamas alasam brigades was claiming
responsibility for the launch of rockets
but this is the first time and being the
first time means also that there's going
to be an Israeli reaction towards it
thank you Ali for that update Ali Hashim
live for us in the Kur in southern
Lebanon